[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN FRENKEL: I'm Ben Frankel,
product manager on the Google
Play Instant team,
and I focus on games.
Today, we have Jam City,
King, and Zynga with us
to talk about
Google Play Instant.
But before we get
started, I'm going
to provide you some context
for the panel discussion.
So last year at I/O, we
launched Instant Apps.
And since then, we've
been pretty busy.
We've enabled Instant Apps
on over 1 billion devices,
and we've made major
improvements to our tooling
and Android studio.
And most recently, at the game
developer conference in March,
we announced that Instant Apps
was finally coming to games.
And this week, we were
excited to announce
that Google Play Instant is
now available to all game
developers.
Now, let's take a look at
Google Play Instant in action.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Divine!
[END PLAYBACK]
BEN FRENKEL: So King's
Candy Crush team just
launched that app
this past Tuesday,
and you can check it out
on the Play Store today.
So just think about
that for a second.
That's Candy Crush,
one of the most,
if not the most successful
mobile games ever coming
to Google Play Instant.
And what gets partners
like King excited
is the vision that
bringing instant to games
can transform game discovery.
And we know that
this is possible
because we have seen
this movie before.
Whenever media becomes
instant, consumption goes up.
Speed is a huge
competitive advantage.
We've seen this with
streaming music and movies.
And before that, Google proved
the transformative impact
of speed with instant search.
And we want to do the
same thing for games
because we believe that instant
will do the same thing for you,
the game developer.
Imagine users trying more
games, exploring more genres,
and ultimately finding more
games they love to play.
That would have a transformative
impact on your business.
And over the course of
our early access program,
the data has proven
this theory out.
Today, the most visible
entry point to an Instant App
is the Try Now button,
as you can see here.
And with just the
Try Now button,
partners are already
seeing an up to 20%
increase in user acquisitions.
Again, that impact is
from Try Now alone,
which just scratches the surface
of the overall Google Play
Instant opportunity.
People will also
be able discover
your games through ads,
through the Play Games app,
through social invites, and
banners, and collections
on the Play Store.
And today, we're announcing
that Instant Apps is coming soon
to preregistration.
Soon, players that
preregister can also
get a sneak preview
of your game.
And when you promote
preregistration
through social media,
email, or your website,
users can instantly play that
game from any Android device.
It's an awesome way to introduce
your game to the world.
And as you look at
what our partners have
done with the discovery services
that I just described, and you
hear about what they're excited
about doing in the future,
you'll start to see how
important a role Google Play
Instant can play throughout
the lifecycle of a game.
From the pre-launch phase,
when your goal is to make your
launch as big as possible,
to build the hype machine
around your game.
And once you've
had that big launch
and you've acquired
a bunch of users,
you want your game to go viral.
You want your players to invite
their friends to the party,
so to speak.
And after your game has
been around for a while,
your goals end up changing.
Your focus then turns to
retaining your existing players
and bringing back those
that may have churned.
At each stage, the
right instant experience
can play an integral
growing your game's success.
And there are three types
of instant experiences
among the many, many that
we saw among our partners.
It was very difficult to
choose just these three.
But I wanted to highlight
these three today for you.
The first is the minigame.
A minigame is often
a gaming experience
that is complimentary
to the full game
and is a great fit
for preregistration.
Danceville's minigame here
lets you choreograph a routine
by manipulating the
individual limbs
on this awesome-looking
character here.
And once you are done, you
can share an animated GIF
with all of your friends.
It offers endless
combinations of moves
and plenty of entertainment
to occupy players
all the way through to the
eventual launch of the game.
The second is what I'm calling
the core gameplay preview.
And the goal of
this archetype is
to provide a glimpse
of what players
will experience
after the tutorial
and introductory levels.
This is a great game and a great
type for different experiences
that have a deep upgrade
system, for example,
such as Zombie Gunship
Revenant, like you can see here.
In this example, the
installed app at the top
typically starts you off
with just a single weapon.
It's not unusual to let people
slowly acclimate to new game
mechanics and so forth.
So you start off with
a single machine gun,
and the zombie horde
that's arriving up there
is arriving at a
relatively modest pace.
Contrast this with the
instant experience, which you
can see down here on the left.
In this one, you don't
just get one machine gun,
but you get two machine guns.
You get a high-power sniper
rifle and hellfire missiles.
The whole experience is intended
to get your adrenaline pumping,
and is a great fit for Try
Now for ads and other user
acquisition channels.
And if you're focused on
bringing back churned users,
the game highlights pattern
might be the right fit for you.
The Candy Crush experience
is a great example of this.
To build their Instant
App, the Candy Crush team
selected five levels
from the more than 3,000
available in the full game,
starting with level 16
going all the way
up to level 590.
And each was selected to
highlight a unique combination
of game mechanics.
I really like playing level
590, which you can see here.
There's a conveyor belt that
perpetually moves candies
around.
And there is this really
fascinating portal right
in the middle of it, which
you can't see right now--
you can maybe see there now--
and through which candies
magically disappear.
The goal of this
type of experience
is to provide a
glimpse of what you've
been missing out on since
the last time you played.
And it's very effective.
So now that you have
a sense of the role
Google Play Instant can play
throughout the lifecycle
of a game, let's
turn our attention
to how you build these
types of experiences.
And just like we want to make
it as easy as possible for users
to start playing
your games, we also
want to make it easier for
you, the game developer,
to build these experiences.
And we've made a substantial
investment in this area.
First, we've adapted
the Instant App
framework to better suit
the unique needs of game
developers.
There are three changes that
we made to the framework.
We raised the size
limit to 10 megabytes,
we enabled the
progressive download
of assets and executable
code, and very importantly,
we integrated with game
engines and added support
for native code and OpenGL.
And that last point
is vitally important
because it means you
can use the same code
base as your full game to
build your Instant App.
And by integrating with
game engines like Unity,
we've made it possible
to build with the tools
that you're already
familiar with.
To make this possible
for Unity developers--
possibly many of you in
the audience here today--
we have to work closely with the
world's most widely-used game
engine, Unity.
Through this close
collaboration,
millions of Unity
developers will
be able to optimize their
current and future games
for Google Play Instant.
And to that end, we've built
the Google Play Instant Unity
plug-in.
The plug-in simplifies building
and deploying an Instant App
all from within the
Unity IDE, and it will be
available in the coming weeks.
And if you're a Unity
developer and you
want to start building an
Instant experience today,
I recommend you join
our Unity beta program.
And you can sign up at
this link here in the lower
left-hand corner.
And I'll review
this at the end too
so you don't have to immediately
break out your photos
and take a picture.
And if you sign up today, you'll
get the latest news and access
to beta features.
We're also excited to
announce that Cocos
has added instant support
to their IDE, Cocos Creator.
And they've gone
beyond supporting
Google Play Instant
as a build target
by adding tools that simplify
the process of building
and an Instant App.
Cocos has added two
steps to their standard
build process just for this
purpose, record and refactor
steps.
On the recording step,
you play your game
in the Cocos simulator, which
tracks which assets are used
and when.
And then in the
refactor step, you
use a visual nonlinear
editing-style
tool to define the boundaries
of your instant experience.
And assets are broken
down by category,
as you can see here, to
support further optimizations.
Cocos has made an alpha build
available for the adventurous
to try, and you can
check it out today.
With that, now that
I've set the context,
let's bring our
esteemed panel up
on the stage to talk
about their vision for
and experience
with Instant Apps.
So folks, come on up.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So why don't we kick
things off with each
of you introducing
yourselves, talking bit
about your background
and any other thoughts
you think might be
interesting for the crowd?
MARCELO FERREIRO:
Hello, everyone.
I'm Marcelo Ferreiro.
I'm a director of
engineering at Jam City.
And we were in charge of
creating the Google Play
Instant experience
for Panda Pop game.
OLIVIA YU: Hi, I'm Olivia Yu,
vice president of Platform
Partnerships at King.
And we created two Google
Play Instant experiences,
one with Bubble Witch 3,
and then just recently,
earlier this week on Tuesday,
with Candy Crush Saga.
KYLE RUSHTON: Hello, my
name is Kyle Rushton.
I'm a senior director of product
management at Zynga, where I've
been for the last six years.
And I work at Zynga on our
central product management
team, and I worked in both
the Zynga Solitaire and Words
With Friends 2 Google
Play Instant experiences.
BEN FRENKEL: Awesome.
Thank you for that.
So first question,
how do you see
instant and instant experiences
impacting the overall gaming
landscape?
MARCELO FERREIRO: So the
mobile gaming landscape,
it's more competitive
than ever at this moment.
And we see Google Play Instant
as a very valuable tool
for developers to acquire
new users into their games.
So I think that's a
great [INAUDIBLE]..
BEN FRENKEL: Makes sense.
OLIVIA YU: Yeah.
So at King, I think we think it
can completely change the way
that games are discovered.
So there's a ton of different
untapped opportunities
that we're looking
into, whether it's
advertising, cross-promotion
in our games,
social, so there's a bunch
of different opportunities
that we haven't even looked
at for Google Play Instant.
So there's a lot of
untapped potential.
KYLE RUSHTON: Yes, so I
think in the short term,
when thinking about
app store discovery,
we'll ultimately see more
consumers trying games, which
will ultimately lead to more
installs and longer and better
engagement.
But thinking longer
term, I think
it will allow
developers to reshape
the way they think about
discovery in the first place,
and allows us to think outside
the box about how we bring
our experiences to consumers
in ways that are outside
of traditional app store.
BEN FRENKEL: Awesome.
So couple other questions
here for you guys.
What instant use cases have
you tried, and what use cases
are you most excited about?
MARCELO FERREIRO: So for us,
we built the first 10 levels
of the game for users to play.
And then they are
able to carry over
their progress into the full
app when they install it.
So it's more like the core
gameplay that you made.
And in the future,
we see that we're
going to explore
probably sharing
the game with your friends.
BEN FRENKEL: Right.
So this would be like a
social invite use case.
MARCELO FERREIRO: Yes, yes.
Now that Facebook, it's--
BEN FRENKEL: Got you.
MARCELO FERREIRO: Yeah.
BEN FRENKEL: Olivia?
OLIVIA YU: So I think
I mentioned earlier,
I think we're pretty excited
about all the different use
cases, probably specifically on
the performance marketing side
once it's available.
And then also for our
side, also cross-promotion.
It's really important, as
you brought up earlier.
We have a ton of lapse
players on Candy Crush Saga,
so it's a great way for
us to bring players back,
for them to see
everything that's
happened with the game, all the
new features, and for people
to remember about
the game again.
So I think those are
the main use cases
we're pretty excited about.
And social as well,
as Marcelo mentioned.
BEN FRENKEL: Seems
to be a common theme.
OLIVIA YU: Yes.
KYLE RUSHTON: Yeah.
So to date, we've been focused
primarily or almost exclusively
on Try Now, and trying
to optimize conversion
funnel through app store.
I think what I'm most excited
about, and perhaps is--
we've already said social
a few times, a little bit
part of my Zynga DNA as well--
is absolutely social
invites and social sharing.
I think on native--
driving virality
and social growth
has always been challenging,
because on the recipient side
of that experience,
there's always
a lot of friction for a
user receiving an invite
to think about what they've
received, go to the app store,
download the app, install
the app, and then ultimately
potentially play
through [INAUDIBLE],,
and then find out what
their friend was actually
trying to share with them.
But in a world of instant
where you can just
share that experience,
perhaps play a move in Words
With Friends, share
it with your friend
and they immediately
open the game board,
is really transformative
in the way
we would think about
discovery and sharing
an app in the first place.
BEN FRENKEL: Excellent.
So a common theme
here, social good.
And there's lots of
other opportunities
as well I'd love to
hear thoughts on.
But all the things that you've
implemented so far, what's
been the impact you've seen?
And what do you
anticipate in the future
from the next project that you
do with Google Play Instant?
MARCELO FERREIRO: Well,
I think social will be
really important in that sense.
Being able to just click and
being able to play the game.
That's going to be
really important.
It removes the friction
of the installation, which
is where people actually
are eager to play the game,
and they probably need
to wait 10, 15, 20
seconds to download it.
And being able to take
advantage of that eagerness,
and I think that's going to be
really important in the future.
BEN FRENKEL: Thank you.
OLIVIA YU: Yeah.
So from our side, we
actually see a lot of users,
like a high intent to install.
And then we've
actually seen a lot
of users who played the
instant game actually
go to install Bubble Witch
3 or Candy Crush Saga,
so that's what we're
really excited about.
And then I think
there's different ways
to continue to optimize the
funnel from instant to actually
installing the game.
KYLE RUSHTON: Yeah.
So we've been really encouraged
by the level of engagement
we've seen with the
Try Now experience,
and the demand we're seeing
from the consumer side of people
really being interested just
to check something out and not
necessarily download
the full experience.
But our focus has
been purely on driving
installs and conversion.
I think looking forward, in
addition to moving forward
that experience, we'll
also look to drive
things like re-engagement
and re-activations
and other core metrics that
are part of the experience
beyond just optimization
of the installation funnel.
BEN FRENKEL: That
makes a lot of sense.
So we've heard from
you what you've
done, what the impact has been.
But let's shift the
conversation to talking about
how you build the
instant app, and how you
design an instant experience.
So let's start off
with you, Olivia.
What factors do you think make
for a great instant experience?
OLIVIA YU: I think, for us,
it was really important--
you're pretty much
playing instantly,
and to make sure
that the player feels
like they're in pretty much
the experience right away.
And we really picked, as you'd
shown earlier, really exciting
levels.
So we wanted to make sure we
had really great, exciting,
and engaging levels for
the user to experience.
So that was, for us,
really important.
That's why we've selected
certain levels, as you can see.
So certain levels
have certain boosters,
certain features
to make sure it's
really different for every
level that they experience
within the Google Play
Instant experience.
BEN FRENKEL: Excellent.
KYLE RUSHTON: Yeah.
Could you rephrase the--
restate the question?
BEN FRENKEL: Yeah,
so what factors make
for a great instant experience?
KYLE RUSHTON: Oh, yeah.
Sorry, missed it
for a second there.
So yeah, so certainly,
speed is important.
So getting people immediately
into the core experience.
I think it probably
goes without saying,
but I also think it's important
to redesign for the use case.
So at Zynga, with
optimization of installs
being our primary
driver, we were really
trying to get an experience
that was concise and short so
that it ended in a
clear opportunity
to expose a user to installing
the full experience.
I think if you were doing
something like a social invite,
or using it for cross-promotion,
or user acquisition,
or different channels,
you might have
to think about the design for
that use case specifically.
So I think use case is really
important to understand,
and exactly what KPI
you're trying to drive
when building the experience.
So it's probably not necessarily
a one-size-fits-all answer.
BEN FRENKEL: Gotcha.
Marcelo?
MARCELO FERREIRO: Well, for
us, what made sense was to--
as I mentioned before-- build
the first part of the game,
basically because
we know it's strong.
So I wanted to share that,
and having the possibility
to then move to the full app
and be able to carry over
that progress.
That was the use case
that we [INAUDIBLE]..
But we see, in the future,
another possibilities
of making, probably
in another games
that we do in Jam City, like
testing different use cases,
and optimize those
for each game.
BEN FRENKEL: So I have
a followup for you.
So building a game that meets
the 10-megabyte size limit
sounds--
probably for many of you--
to be pretty intimidating.
But all of you have successfully
done something like that.
And what my question is for
you is, as you built out
the instant experience
for Panda Pop, what
are the kinds of things
you learned about both
that process as
well as maybe things
that you learned about the
installed apps infrastructure
and so forth?
MARCELO FERREIRO:
So our first idea
was to make the instant
app 20 levels long.
Being able to go back
and forth, [INAUDIBLE]
them up, and then go to the
game, and then go to the map
again.
But, again, we realize
that we weren't
going to achieve the size
limit goal that we had.
So at that point, we
get together with a team
and basically decided to only
do gameplay and do the first 10
levels.
So that enabled us to
remove a lot of textures,
scenes that we weren't using,
localization strings that
needs to be stripped off.
And what we learn is
that every little thing
that you can remove
from the app,
remove it, because its
going to be important.
Remove the plug-ins,
remove the localizations
that you don't use.
Even the smallest pre-fab,
it's important to take it out.
BEN FRENKEL: It's all cut out.
MARCELO FERREIRO: Yeah.
Yeah, so take away everything.
We try to do it in a way
where we could build it
on top of the regular game,
so we benefit from the changes
that we made in the full app.
So I would also recommend
that, if possible.
BEN FRENKEL: So you're saying
that through that process,
you were able to make
optimizations that
then impacted your full game?
Is that right?
MARCELO FERREIRO: Yes.
In fact, there were two
things that we benefit
from building the instant app.
One was, we improve
the way we were
making [INAUDIBLE] animations.
And that made the
application run
smoother and with a
reduced memory footprint.
So we basically, in the
full app, we gain memory
and we gain performance.
So it was truly beneficial.
BEN FRENKEL: That's awesome.
And Kyle, why don't
you talk a little bit
about your experience.
You converted at least
a couple of games
that I've had an
opportunity to play,
and what was your experience
like, and how did you do that?
KYLE RUSHTON: Yeah.
So fortunately, in the case of
Zynga Solitaire, the full app
itself was just around
the 10 megabyte mark,
so we didn't have much
difficulty getting it
under the threshold
in that case.
In the case of Words
With Friends 2--
I think this goes back
to the design piece of it
as well-- was really just
having a clear focus of what we
wanted to bring to consumers.
And so for us, we launched
Words With Friends 2
about six months ago.
One of the new
features we launched
with that was a feature
called Solo Series,
which allows users to play
against AI-powered bots.
We thought that was
a really good match
for the instant experience,
so we focused exclusively
on bringing a subset of Solo
Series to the instant app.
By having that
clear focus, we were
able to remove a
lot of other stuff
that was tangential
or unrelated.
And so we could really
reduce the app size
and build a really
clean experience
without a lot of the other--
I don't call it fluff,
but aspects of the app.
BEN FRENKEL: Also, so
to synthesize that,
you're saying that you can cut
out, let's say, lots of levels,
but another thing
is to just focus
on one particular slice
of the experience.
KYLE RUSHTON: Yeah, exactly.
I think that is a good summary.
BEN FRENKEL: Excellent.
Any thoughts, Olivia?
OLIVIA YU: Yeah.
So I think for us, we just
focus a lot on the gameplay.
And then we took
out the Saga map,
we don't have any
other features,
and a lot of our
games always have
a narrative in the beginning,
and a [INAUDIBLE],, so we
obviously took everything
else so it was only just
focus on the gameplay.
So that's what we
wanted to focus on.
BEN FRENKEL: Makes
a lot of sense.
And we've heard similar
things from a lot
of our other partners as well.
It's either
stripping out assets,
or choosing a select gameplay.
But I think it's really good
to get some additional context
from you up here.
So I wanted to
particularly talk to you
about some of the challenges
related to developing
a instant experience in Unity.
And what are some of the
things that you ended up
having to do and learn
through that process?
MARCELO FERREIRO: Well, as you
mentioned before, the biggest
challenge for us was size.
BEN FRENKEL: Right.
MARCELO FERREIRO: [INAUDIBLE].
So as I mentioned
before, we needed
to change the way we were
doing [INAUDIBLE] animations.
Because what we were using
at the time, the files
that it was producing,
they were bigger,
and they were also taking up
a lot of memory in the game.
And after that, we
also needed to refactor
certain parts of the code
to be able to only use
the scene of the gameplay.
I think those were the
two biggest challenges
that we needed to make.
But in the end, we end up with
a more modularized obligation,
and we were able to benefit from
that in a technical way also.
So it was a win-win for us.
BEN FRENKEL: Excellent.
And so, looking
forward, overall,
what kind of
developments do you see
emerging in the instant gaming
space and the coming years?
You can go as far in the
future as you would like,
but I'd love to hear
your thoughts on how you
see the whole space evolving.
MARCELO FERREIRO:
I think that this
is going to be probably the--
I would say the future
of user acquisition.
Also, the social part of being
able to share a link and start
playing right away.
That's probably going
to be the future apps
that we're going to see.
And of course, we are
going to benefit from that.
BEN FRENKEL: Awesome.
OLIVIA YU: I still
think, as you mentioned,
especially with
new games coming,
so there's also a way
to also fully leverage
their preregistration
on Google Play
so players can actually try the
game before they preregister
and actually install it.
So I think that's another way.
And then depending on where you
are in the stage for your game,
there could be different
instant games experiences.
KYLE RUSHTON: Yeah.
I'm really excited to see
what the creativity of game
developers will bring
to Google Instant.
And I think there will be
some breakout mechanic built
on top of Google Play Instant
that to date would not
be possible.
And so I think once you
think about it from a design
perspective, and
what you can bring
once there's no friction
between a current user
and a potential user,
or a re-activated user,
I think we'll be able to
build new mechanics on top
of that that are breakout.
BEN FRENKEL: I wanted to give
you a big round of applause.
Thank you for being here.
OLIVIA YU: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN FRENKEL: And I hope
you all learned a lot.
And I just wanted
to close things out
with a collection
of links so that you
can follow up and take action
on the things you learn today.
So yes, taking a photo
is definitely preferable,
because this last URL is
probably difficult to remember.
So Google Play
Instant, that's where
your getting started guide is.
You can see the technical
documentation there.
There's a beta
sign-up for Unity,
so if you want to build
a game with Unity today,
we encourage that, obviously.
Then sign up here to be
part of our instant beta.
And if you're interested,
and adventurous,
and are willing to try something
that's hot off the press,
the alpha build of Cocos
Creator with the new features
that we described today, you
can go to this link here.
And it's very stable, I've been
told, by the people from Cocos.
So go check it out.
It's really cool, we were
demoing it all week at Tent C,
or whatever it is called,
and it was stable.
But either way, go check it out.
I think you're going to
really get a kick out of it,
and it's only going to
get better from here.
So thank you all for your time,
and enjoy what remains of I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]